and speaking of losing a leg i see a.g
luck is here
um
and i want i want to i do want to
i do want to thank him because he's
running our clip channel youtube.com
rotc media
um he has been uh been doing a great job
uh and i i do wanna wish him
[Music]
i do wanna wish him um a speedy recovery
obviously um for those people that don't
know
an angie luxer boy and we joke around a
lot but
he
he did lose a leg in a terrible clipping
accident i've talked about this before
um it took a while i mean i mean this is
very recent
it took a while for the money to come in
and
um but he got the money and uh he
finally got his prosthetic like he sent
me a picture
i asked of course i asked him it was
okay to show it um so this is uh
this is a prosthetic leg he just got put
on uh
look man a lot of people get i mean we
joke around on the shoulder i mean a lot
of people get prosthetic legs and stuff
um and it's just going to take a while
to get used to it you know
it's going to take a while to get used
to it apparently the prosthetic leg you
got was from a
cyberpunk the ps4 version but still
that's pretty cool
it's a pretty cool leg and um
i just want to wish him a a speedy
recovery you know
a speedy recovery um
it looks like hey man it looks
like you're on your way
to a speedy recovery that's what i call
them and this i i coined this by the way
and it's funny because
he looks pissed at me because i
trademarked this so he can't even use it
i call him a.g no luck and yes
by the way i wanted to point that out
too
i am in cyberpunk i'm not even kidding
you
y'all are playing cyberpunk right
yeah you guys are playing of course
you're playing cyberpunk y'all in
cyberpunk
playing cyberpunk so
obviously cyberpunk is
i think it's fantastic um i've been
having a fun time playing it
see where is it i have it here somewhere
um
so there's a character in the game early
on in the game so there's no spoilers in
this either brother i
won't spoil it for you but there there
is a character in the game
named royce okay
so there's a character in the in the
game named royce which
i know that's like oh there's there's
probably a bunch of you that have
played games and there's characters in
it but royce is a is
you would agree a unique name
um so whenever there's like
somebody named royce in a game it's it's
it's kind of cool you know i'm like oh
[ __ ] someone my name you you don't see
that a lot
this is um the problem with this bothers
me about the cyberpunk thing it's not
that they use the roy st royce is a
common name
why the [ __ ] does this guy look like me
i'm not sure what the [ __ ] man
why the [ __ ] does this character look
like me
what is this about so they have a
character named royce in cyberpunk and
he looks just like me
and i'll be honest with you tiny spoiler
if you haven't played but honestly it's
a tiny spoiler in the grand scheme of
the 50 hours of gameplay
but i have to say this you get a choice
at one point whether you kill him or not
i blew this motherfucker's brains out
because there could only be one and i
don't even care it's in the video game
world i don't even care how it affects
the game
i blew this motherfucker's head off
so hey cyberpunk guys use my likeness if
you want
i get it how about a little bit of
credit that's what
i'm not kidding you this is what the guy
looks like his name is royce which
whatever
i get it man people are gonna be named
royce but he looks like me
all royces look alike that's racist and
you know it rob
that's extremely racist um
i don't know which one of you [ __ ]
are doing it no idea
but this makes me feel uncomfortable
i killed him i blew his brains out
i kill you guys too serious you're right
there's some freudian issues i'll be
killing myself
but hey i was able to do it in cyberpunk
but this royce was straight first off i
don't like that because you don't know
this one's sexual orientation
honestly the only thing that would have
happened during that scene if they were
playing outposts in the back
no [ __ ] seriously it's weird right
who would s who at cd pro who's uh at cd
projekt red
it's a polish company does bali song
work for them because that's what i'm
starting to think
are you serious
people already cosplaying him how
let me see something
here you go here's the scene again
it's it's a small spoiler but if you
don't want to see it i get it
five minutes come back in five minutes
okay
come back in five minutes all right here
you go we're on their turn
so what do you
[Music]
yep we'll take it free
cyberpunk royce is prettier i say that's
me let's see a cred
brick got it it's all paid up
here i don't see any [ __ ] brick
around here do you
i don't don't [ __ ] [ __ ] you dude
[Music]
come on can't expect me to pay for this
thing twice and who the [ __ ] are you to
say what can
it can't be you'll pay twice because i
say you'll pay twice
all right you want the flathead i better
see some eddies
i'm talking to you
i'm talking seeing these lord got the
eddies for it
or to offer us a discount big
a discount [ __ ]
you know you never did say who sent you
never did
say who you're working for dexter desean
that's dexter desean
the hard ass punching animal [ __ ] up a
pacifica
nope he's alive well
he sends his regards so you're gonna
consider my offer now
that's what i did to him that's what i
did to him
that's what i did to him because i'm
gonna be the only one
very weird
[ __ ] you other royce
a lot of self-hatred hey man you might
be right i
i will say that you might you might be
right but you know what
don't all right all right
all right [ __ ] cd project i know what
the [ __ ] you're doing
but i'm thinking bali song
also because anywhere should be rob no
don't say that
again
yeah that red that seemed like a real
jerk unlike the railroad exactly